these are always so much fun what's up
reject nation I'm Greg no I'm John we're
gonna watch from nukes top five today
five scary ghost videos to haunt you for
days to come
let's check this app attached it's up to
her afterwards she says that every time
she report to her voice unexplained
horrific screams and growls appear on
her recordings in this clip to prove her
claim she records herself in full view
of a camera and a room full of people
which would make faking the recording
nearly impossible hi it's me again
obviously no one can understand why you
have to scream and neither time
why do you follow the everywhere
under your health that I can't
understand you please can you just try
to not scream
can you try to tell me your name
or what you'd like for us to call you
I had friends with me they understand
things in the spirit world we all want
to try to help I know you came with me
for rolling hills and I told you you
would never have to go back there and
now I'm thinking you need to go
someplace else what
[Music]
just as she claims some terrifying voice
seems to appear near the end of the
recording even though in the video she
delivered she needs to be delivered from
evil oh yeah we saw this on a different
one this one is freaking creepy this is
pretty freakin
posted this video claims that this
incident actually caused them to move
from this house okay so really I didn't
know that and we no longer live in that
house as far as here we haven't really
had anything we do have a wooden picture
arm wall that keeps falling down but we
don't know what's causing it
next up we have the restroom stall those
Oh No what line a path or a ghost
haunting a bathroom
no bad what
so are these real ghost videos the
latest video craze so I leave it to you
to decide this is why the government is
shutting down
that little kid explores you begins to
find old crumpled pieces of paper inside
the covers however I pay you no mind
almost is this someone or something is
watching him as he explores the houses
cabinets
[Music]
no way
you know what I'm out of the light and
when he checks his footage later you
finds that there might have been another
paper on a higher shelf seems to move on
its own a paper this is language so
didn't find an actual curse scribble and
pieces of paper spread throughout the
house or it's just an elaborate hoax you
decide I mean that's like really well
Lantis hoax if that's the case yeah what
if there's like a hitting cut there
back the German ghost hunting group and
a Papa PE caught one of the most bizarre
videos of the supposed apparition that
I've ever seen
and the Papas investigating the haunted
house and Eber stop Germany couple who
lives there says they've heard and seen
very strange things including the
terrifying disembodied head of a little
boy peeking out from inside their
bathtub and the Papa did indeed get
strange electromagnetic readings inside
a bathtub of a little bland head
appeared
but creepiest of all as the group walks
into a hallway there's static camera
this seems to reach up and touch one of
the investigators on the back yeah the
pop team says that they only notice the
incident after watching their footage
back since there's only a brick wall
next to them in this video there was
nowhere that this small hand could have
reached out from how fun anything it
might be the investigator Chris reaching
around to touch his own back it should
be noted that the angle of his arms and
paws would be absolutely bizarre and
awesome chris is a pretty big guy and
has very large hands you can follow the
ghost hunting routes investigations over
on their Channel and the Papa PE the
sell his next book was filmed in a
mental institution in a southwestern
city in the Netherlands now I can't even
remotely pronounce the dutch name of the
city so I just won't try but this is
what it was filmed at one of the ends
- she's holding cells for patients under
psychiatric observation by the way the
institution was also a former prison and
this room was originally used as a
solitary confinement holding cell nice
so obviously the room has a dark history
one night guards monitoring man read a
security camera
notice something very strange
I don't hear anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
does store a spiderweb
but just what is it better with you
decide thanks for watching if you see a
video anywhere that you think would be
perfect for the top five suited to me
and new stop by at gmail.com and follow
me on twitter and you stop by for other
random stuff
what if those guards were just messing
around and we don't remember what they
were really saying and they just put
different sometimes in there and they
were like okay now now make it pass now
make it pass and then react
yes literally then going I mocked this
up on after-effects over the weekend
would let me know what you guys think
this is a pretty spooky let's break some
of this down or the experts now that's
right we've been on several paranormal
hunts we know what we're doing
the first one with the lady with the
voice recording in some ways might be
the creepiest one man I think it's my
favorite because there's so much build
to it and yeah there's like I said he
says here the originals uncut so he had
to edit it down just for this video
specifically however he workaround that
because if this is an uncut take right
and then you're hearing her do the
recording what she's playing back
matches perfectly it's not some retakes
she's doing they didn't pre recorded
that into whatever that video recording
device is called she had to like redo
the whole thing to go what I'm getting
at here
she's not like mimicking a pass like a
delivery of this thing so as to plot
where she is then we just don't know but
but yeah it would be a lot it would be a
lot of conniving to do that I think yeah
I mean it came out great if that's the
case is the old way good see you could
fake it but they're recording like that
you're recording over if there's you
can't like pre maybe there is a way to
hack it it's not I don't know about yeah
I like modern music recording where you
can like record back over and add new
yeah exactly you already met it looks
like a you know pretty og tape recorder
or something like that yeah and it made
me sit here going more of these should
just be audio based yeah because yeah
like there is something about just
getting to watch this and even though it
is cut up here getting to watch a
prolonged stretch of it and then just
see the recording take place cuz ii you
gets into playback it chills your bones
per second anything anything was gonna
happen i was like what's the point of
this video
how long you but these tic toc ones are
funny man
the more of a rabbit hole you go down
tick-tock you find out it's more than
just goofy dancing videos all kinds of
creepy things you could find on
tick-tock me we saw the video of the
girl who who saw that with her dog seen
the shadow then disappearing but i
didn't know about the
with her moving to a different house
let's be skeptical here it's important
to be skeptical about these kind of
things she could have just moved for
many other reasons and saw that this
video was trending so I'm going to you
know like capitalize off of this a
little bit then again here's the other
side I have no idea what she does for a
living
I have no idea what she stands to gain
or benefit from being a tick tock
sensation if this lines up with her
career goals yeah or something she could
just be a casual user the tick tock app
and happened to record this but then
there's the other side too she made the
right choice if that's the case I would
absolutely move in a heartbeat if I saw
anything like that I wouldn't take time
to figure it out or bring it pretty soon
what's the point you didn't move
somewhere else if that is the case if
she is telling the truth 100% agree with
that motive oh yeah by all means at
least you got a try I mean nowadays
ghosts usually follow you places yes
you know Uli's gotta put in the effort
and I don't know I mean she she came
across authentic enough whatever no man
but that footage still chills me and the
other tick talked to I mean like the one
where you're in like it looks like some
kind of shopping complex or something
like that and then there's like the
little kids silhouette yeah oh that one
was really creepy not not that you
couldn't have faked that's like bringing
your nephew to work or something like
that but yeah it was it was really well
yeah it's really creepy but super fake
yeah yeah I don't buy it
any time where I see like a perfect like
no no there's a kid there yeah like
there's probably just a child yeah if
you could have planted it and then my
brains always racing when I'm trying to
find the flaw okay so when he goes
through the stores that are swinging
open there could have easily been the
kid just hiding someplace he gets far
enough so the kid can get in position
they don't buy him round yeah yeah say
beeps we solved it my favorite one would
be the one who's stuck in the back
that's just a poor poor purgatory
situation to get all that ghosts wants
us to get out of that baseball at the
end like what's the story with this guy
so this goes die in the toilet that
happens to people it's a sad thing it's
just a shitty situation to be left there
as a ghost especially if you're left
with some unfortunate unfinished
business you know being murdered like
mid dumped or something like that
only terrible or Chipotle got - you
don't want to diet don't I love the ones
from other countries because a lot of
the times when they're doing some type
of paranormal investigation they're
usually you know chanting or reciting
some type of Prayer throughout which
from my American mind hearing this
foreign voice do it and with just the
emotional intensity of it always makes
it that much creepier and scarier than
me it's not disrespect to anyone in
America whose religious I just don't
think I'd be as like spooked if you're
you know chanting the Our Father or Hail
Mary you know it's something that's a
lot of much we're unfamiliar with in its
at a foreign language it always freaks
me out this one I mean the whole thing
read like hoax to me then when we got to
the bit with the fire
that's just such an unexpected thing to
occur the fact that it was in multiple
places it looked like it was wherever
those papers yeah and it seems like you
summoned the demon dude got really
creative with some flash tape yeah but
yeah that wouldn't especially when the
drop came on that one that one satisfied
me at least is a you know enjoyer of
chilling videos I think the thing about
the the ones from other countries and
stuff and especially when people seem to
be kind of rattled in our yeah praying
to themselves or whatever is like it
adds a layer of authenticity I think
just because you know it's a little less
sounds obvious but it's like less
familiar it's like if I see an American
video I start thinking of all the ways
of like oh well you could easily edit
this on your phone and like I know
technology's everywhere but there's
something about that video that did kind
of feel more authentically like oh yeah
this is just a guy exploring yeah if
your channel is solely dedicated to
supernatural things I'm actually way
less likely to buh-bye not for my nukes
top five which is about assembling from
other peoples than us deciding for
ourselves when it comes to like whatever
this German channel is with a little boy
hand in the purple room your whole
channel is dedicated to this ideally you
mean you should be the ones who are
attracting the most coasts and
everything right ones who know how to
find them yeah yeah it makes just that
much more suspicious of you I don't know
the whole thing with the hand it's a
cool effect what it just looks like an
effect to me yeah I'm kind of with you
on that I thought it was well shot to
them yeah but I am a bit skeptical too
when it is
ghost-hunting channel to get some like
really good [ __ ] on tape I immediately
searched I mean it's like you need it to
work for your channel like an out horse
it's more believable to me when it's not
dedicated at this yeah was like oh I
accidentally caught this but it's it's
too much not to share so what I'm saying
is I believe the tic-tock use more than
I do believe in this last one it's
alright it's cool about went as expected
it's super creepy at the same time
there's nothing surprising about this
especially with the enormous setup of
was a prison then it was an insane
asylum then it was a witch cult and then
they sacrificed many animals and little
children top of it is about what I
expect when you tell me all that any
time you have a cell that that was made
or on top of like a-- and a sane asylum
and then one that became a solid
solitary confinement is just a bad
recipe for any kind of spiritual
activity i've never heard one of these
ghost videos go by with a solitary
confinement that didn't end up as a
pretty nest yeah was the big bright
light a part of this or was it just this
it was part of this part of it yeah it's
supposed to go off and then harold
passes in the corner of the frame okay
so the light is just the part of the
room I thought that light at first was
like yeah of spiritual presence I was
like that's more out there than the
shadow is you read too much into things
no you got to be a bit skeptical gem now
to be true I know you do so you could do
your mmm that's why I want them to be
true cuz I have no I'll make it up to
you I tend to go oh you know that's fine
if it gets like a belch after dinner
it's a chef's compliment alright guys
well which one of these do you think is
real these are so fun subscribe he's
waking me up you tend to start these and
I'm like kind of tired and suddenly I'm
like I'm awake now subscribe to the real
rejects clicked our notifications really
get notified recommend other channels or
other videos for us we'd love that make
sure to subscribe for new top 5 as well
and last but not least we'll come this
with up
erricka Tuesday Erica is a woman I've
gotten to know a lot better actually in
the past week or two something was
somewhere there I gotta say from a
sincere standpoint you are hilarious
strange and all the right way
thank you feel like you're so unique
wildly engaging very creative wonderful
artist a very genuine human being as
well someone who I least I believe to be
a very honest considerate empathetic
human being I could actually go on and
on when it comes to Erica because you
are someone who I can see why John has
treasured a friendship with you for so
long and now I'm glad that I get to call
you a friend as well you know that I
love you too and I know that things have
also been a little bit challenging
especially in the last couple of weeks
so send in a little extra love and hey I
mean this is a perfect video to shout
you out on because you were the one who
introduced me to five nights at freddys
and each one of these like sitting in a
chair waiting for something to pop out
at you so in a way in a spiritual way I
feel like this is a perfect video show
you huh yeah yeah and I just wanted to
show you